we have now good news solve the
technical difficulties with major
Garrett's interview with vice president
Mike Pence it happened just a few
moments ago here's our conversation mr.
vice president thank you for being with
us Thank You major well president Trump
declare a national emergency tonight in
his address to the nation when the
president addresses the nation tonight
he'll be laying out the facts to the
American people of what is a genuine
humanitarian and security crisis at our
southern border major as we sit here
today nearly 60,000 people over the past
several months have attempted to come
into our country illegally but for the
first time the predominant number our
families and unaccompanied children and
it simply is overwhelming the ability of
our Customs and Border Patrol to deal
with it add to that human trafficking
the flow of narcotics the apprehension
in the last year of 17,000 individuals
at our southern border with previous
criminal histories and the American
people will hear from the president
tonight that we have a crisis and we
have to address it and the time has come
for the Democrats to come to the table
and start negotiating not just in the
partial government shutdown but but to
address the humanitarian and security
crisis all too well mr. vice president
the idea of this national emergency in
going around the appropriations process
is something the president has suggested
the country is waiting to find out has
he made a determination is he going to
use tonight's bully pulpit to say that
well the president was asked if it was
something he was considering and he said
it's something that we're looking at I
was a few days but the look the fact is
a legal review done here at the White
that Congress should do its job and come
to the table we spent the entire weekend
in this room with senior aides for the
Republican and Democrat leadership on
Capitol Hill we listened carefully to
what their priorities were what the
president put forward is a reaffirmation
of his determination
to build a wall on the southern border
but the president said it could be a
steel barrier recognized you can see
second century Sun I think there were
many Democrats in the leadership
meetings who expressed concern about
concrete and the president said we'll
build a steel barrier but the president
also listened carefully to their
priorities about additional humanitarian
and medical resources additional
technology for screening at all of our
ports of entry we've incorporated those
reforms including legal reforms in the
proposal that we have on the table it's
a reflection of the president's priority
to build a wall to provide resources to
customs Border Patrol and immigrations
and Customs Enforcement but and also our
proposal also incorporates what we're
hearing from the Democrats but the fact
is what we heard over the course of this
weekend is they're not even willing to
negotiate until the president reopens
the government and the American people
the American people deserve better than
that they deserve the Democrats to come
back to the table start negotiating and
we believe we can resolve this the
legislative provider you have to put
them together why can't the rest of the
government unaffected by DHS Department
of Homeland Security funding be funded
and then deal with this issue separately
why must there be a partial government
shutdown affecting all these agencies
that have nothing to do with this
underlying debate well really for two
reasons number one is that these are the
bills that were remaining at the end of
the year if you can set we're not you
did that when you were in the house well
right but the fact is as we've also
listened to Democrats they're calling
for changes in our ability to accept
applications for asylum at our embassies
in Guatemala El Salvador and Honduras
that would require a change in the State
Department's appropriations bill
so the point what the president is
saying is let's resolve this issue with
with the crisis on the southern border
if there are other changes and other
bills let's make those changes but the
truth is major you've been around
Washington for a while you know that we
could resolve this in a matter of hours
if the Democrats will come to the table
and start negotiating in good faith and
the American people also deserve to know
on the very first day of this partial
government shutdown the president sent
me to Capitol Hill to make a good-faith
offer that would have avoided the
shutdown all together now we're three
weeks in and and tonight the American
people the the president will take his
case directly to the American people you
know three weeks in I think a lot of
people who are affected by this saying
three we could sent somebody do
something yeah the question for this
speech tonight is whether the president
has a policy in search of an emergency
vice president Pence told major Garrett
that the president will present facts
but one of the facts he presented that
17,000 criminals have been apprehended
at the border they haven't been
apprehended at the southern border which
is what this emergency is supposed to be
about he's using in figures in that
interview that are not related to the
case the president is going to make and
the other point I would make is that the
president's talking about a humanitarian
crisis there is a situation but the
question is does the border wall solve
that particular crisis or would more
funding for agents to process those
people be the the policy you want and so
those are two of the hurdles the
president has to clear but the fact that
the vice president used numbers that
have been fact checked by The Washington
Post McClatchy and others is a weakness
in their case and that is why the
Democrats want to have a response
immediately after the address so they
can fact check it in real time or
present or present their their present
their side of the story yeah we will
have more of that interview in our next
hour and we will talk with major Garrett
live at 8 o'clock CBS News as you know
we'll bring you president Trump's oval
office speech and the Democratic
response to night Jeff gore enters our
coverage on that starting at 9:00
o'clock Eastern 8:00 central right here
on CBS